1,400 army medics are now in Wuhan ready
to work in a newly built hospital for
coronavirus patients completed in just
nine days the images of supplies on the
way and more medical help on hand the
Chinese government wants its people and
the world to see China has criticized
the United States for no substantive
help with the outbreak and accused the
US government of spreading fear and
panic the new facility is modeled after
a similar hospital built outside Beijing
during the SARS crisis 17 years ago the
number of dead from the corona virus now
exceeds that of SARS a second Wuhan
hospital is expected to be finished by
the end of the week together they will
have 2,500 beds for those infected with
the virus there's frustration and anger
on social media over conditions for the
infected and doctors in Wuhan China's
central government the first day back
for central workers after the prolonged
holiday focused on easing concern over
the supply of needed medical equipment
it also looked to build confidence in
the economy the second largest in the
world after factories have been shut and
businesses closed because of the virus
goo Booma goodie far as far as we know
many export companies are now quickly
resuming their production capacity and
various localities are also taking
targeted measures to help create a sound
and favorable business environment the
central authorities and local
governments have all made plans to
introduce targeted measures to help
businesses resume their operations
during the first day of trading since
the Lunar New Year break the Chinese
mainland markets closed sharply down
around 8 percent shy of the 10 percent
one-day decreased limit set by the
markets to help curb the slide China's
central bank injected 174 billion
dollars into the market but the spread
of the virus is far from over in the
lockdown of millions of Chinese still
does not have an end date so the viruses
impact on the future of China's
financial markets and economy remains
unclear it's got hilar al jazeera
beijing kc wall is CEO up attune that is
an employee motivation platform he says
fear over the outbreak is already
changing company and workers behavior I
think we're just starting to see the
impacts and the fear is starting to take
over and here in Japan people's
behaviors are start
to change you know like realistically
we're only seeing like a 10 to 20
percent impact of tourist numbers type
of thing on economy rather than what we
saw we're like 90 percent with South
Korean tourists last year when that
fight was going on but so I think it's
just the beginning like it's really
changing behaviors fear is becoming more
pervasive so there's a lot happening
right I think you've seen like a selling
out of masks people can't get masks and
on the secondary market the different
apps that are selling those are selling
10 for like $100 here in Japan for
example people are trying to stay out of
public transportation here in Tokyo for
example where we don't have so many
cases yet but fear is starting to happen
and people that have the ability to you
know drive around in the car which is a
luxury are doing that to get to meetings
rather than be on transportation but
specifically here for Japan what I'm
really hopeful can happen is remote work
might actually really happen so Japan
has been talking about changing the work
style for a long time and now companies
are starting to send their employees
home and just stay away for a month or
so so I think we're starting to see
people take actions whether it's in
Japan whether it's in South Korea Taiwan
or China by the fear that we're seeing
so it is changing behavior a lot in
economic and company behavior